just in the last several days i weighed
in on a tweet that in my view was
conveying some poorly thought out and
schmaltzy
and probably bad advice about how we
should think about ourselves in the
present and you've all seen this kind of
thing
in this case it was somebody talking
about how he was in politics and when he
got into it when he was 15 and we should
evaluate ourselves from the perspective
of our 15 year old selves and what they
would make of of what we're doing but
you've seen these kind of things all
over the place it could be 15 years old
it could be 13 years old it could be
eight years old it could be you know
your eighth grade self your kindergarten
stuff pick whatever you want it's
somebody from
your childhood or your adolescence who
is you
and you're supposed to
think about what they would think about
you or what they would say to you or
what they would make of you
in the present and of course this is
going to be
quite different depending on who we are
and how old we are in my case i'm 51
years old so if i pick my 11 year old
self that is a gap of 40
years and a lot has happened a lot has
changed not just in me but in the entire
world since that time and maybe you are
20 years old and you're getting this
advice about think about what your 11
year old self would say about you
now that you're out working and you've
got your own place or you're in college
or pick whatever else is going on you
know what would that that 11 year old
think about you what would they make of
you and i think that
in many respects
it could be helpful to to do something
like this but
it is really
poorly thought out advice and it taps
into
a kind of yearning and nostalgia for
a simpler time for
naivete for when you really had things
worked out and now there might be some
people who you know grew up with a great
home life and in in a great culture and
they were like proceeding along and
maturing the way that they should in
their you know childhood and teenage
years and and who knows how how long
we're going to go with is maybe into our
20s but that's not the case for a lot of
us
so just to cut to the chase again i'll
say this in that tweet i was like well
this is terrible advice i wouldn't take
any sort of direction or judgment or
verdict from that idiot 15 year old that
i was at the time
and i think a lot of people shouldn't
either i'm not even sure if i would take
it from my
25 year old self who's a bit closer to
me
in time and in life experience and you
know where that guy was
supposedly going with his life
so
there's a there's a number of uh
different things that i want to sort of
put on the table and this is kind of a
if the shoe fit wears it if this is
helpful for you that's great if not you
know it might just be kind of a
curiosity
so
the first thing i want to say is that
the disconnect is obviously going to be
greater depending on how far back you're
going and how old you currently are so
for people in my generation generation x
to go back to our childhood or
adolescence that is really
a big stretch and not just in terms of
our own age or what we've done or you
know what our health is like it society
has changed immensely
since then i mean i remember when i was
in high school a lot of us didn't even
think that we would finish high school
because we anticipated being in a hot
war with the soviets and warsaw pact and
that we would get you know drafted if if
the area wasn't you know destroyed by
nukes or something like that totally
different era isn't it compared to where
we are in the present or even where we
were
20 years ago so this disconnect
you know the how far it is
um how extensive it is it's really going
to depend on
who we are and
you know
i i would say that there's a lot of
things that stand in the way
of taking what my
earlier self whether it's you know
when i was eight whether i was 20 and
i'm going to give you i'm going to show
you some pictures of the guy who i used
to be in just a minute
what would separate me from him and make
him kind of a
not particularly helpful judge so it was
a different era
bringing
greg from 1987
or
1983 into the present
massive culture shock right i mean think
about the
mediation of our world through the
internet and mobile technology think
about the fact that you're probably
watching this if not on a phone
you're watching it on a tablet or a
laptop
or a desktop computer that has such
incredible
power and connectivity
that
you know what what we would have thought
of back then even the science fiction
isn't even close to where we currently
are think about
all the other things that have massively
changed
in the you know geopolitics of the world
or
what we know about the human body and
health or or the fact that you know
if it was 17 year old onward me he'd
probably be smoking cigarettes like
the proverbial chimney
and you know that's not something that
people are doing quite so much these
days so there's culture shock right and
then
at least in my case it wouldn't pay to
consult my 15 year old or 17 year old or
13 year old self
because that guy
was
very immature
and not just in terms of
being emotionally immature
that was a major problem he had
significant struggles with grief and
anger which there's still traces of
today but i'm a quite different person
he was you know quite insecure about a
number of matters there's also cognitive
and decision-making immaturity you know
our brains aren't fully developed and i
think there was a lot of you know
lack of information
at the time and we could talk about
experiential immaturity that guy
uh if we're going to look at somebody up
until i don't know maybe
well i think i started paying taxes when
i was maybe 17 or so although i was you
know earning back when i was 15.
but you know
there's holding down a job when you're a
teenager and then there's holding a job
as a long succession of jobs when you're
older
and uh you know i've had i've been a
house owner
i've got kids that i've i've had to you
know help raise and see through problems
of their own
uh i'm married with you know a great
spouse and all these sort of things i've
negotiated a whole bunch of health
challenges
um
you know
we could go on and on and on so that
that guy back then didn't know anything
about those those sort of matters except
what he saw adults going through
and he lived in a situation essentially
of dependency right he lived in a family
with a
house that he could go to or he was in
the army and the army was taking care of
him or
you know he went off to college and
lived in the the dorms you know school
uh structured life and told him what to
do from kindergarten on through uh 12th
grade he had jobs but they were kind of
menial jobs as well
and i think you know greg of the
1980s
and the 1990s maybe even into the 2000s
had all sorts of wrong-headed
assumptions about the way the world
worked and what was important and what
wasn't and a extensive lack of
information about many many things some
of which we probably are not all that
responsible for and some of which was
probably my own damn fault for not
paying attention or being interested in
the the right things
and um so i think it would be very
foolish
to make this person here i'll show you
these pictures you know so
these pictures are me
at various ages
from you know childhood
into my 20s when i was in college
this guy i mean look at him do you think
that he has his proverbial crap together
i don't looking back at it and i know
that he thought at the time
that he did
all these clothing choices all of these
ways in which he's looking he thought
that was cool back then or at least you
know um he was taking he was willing to
accept it the earlier on before i
started you know taking control over my
own um
garb and and look and stuff like that
why the hell would i rely on him for
anything you know
and
we could go on and on and so it's
foolish to make that person or really
any other
young person from that time perhaps a
judge an arbiter a critic the person
whose judgment we would value and say is
more important than our own or a
iteration of ourself
closer
in time
i don't think that it's a completely bad
idea to think about what it would be
like to relate to your
past self and there is also an entire
genre
of you know the advice that you would
give as an older person to your younger
self which
you know could be kind of
valuable
but um you know just to sort of like
walk through this what would my 13 year
old self or my 23 year old self or my
18 year old self what would that guy
actually
make of who i am today i think he would
be totally confused
i mean
i had no intention when i was in high
school
of going to college
let alone going on to graduate school
and becoming a professor
which i was for ball state for six years
and then fayetteville state university
for another three years before i left
that job moved up to new york to marry
my now wife and began adjuncting
it would probably blow his mind
that he has for you know more than 10
years had a philosophy-based business
you know
that has clients
really on um
just about
yeah every continent on the earth except
for antarctica at least at one point in
time
so
you know what would he what would he
make of me what would you know he'd
probably look at me and said well you
got fat
that's not great
and look at how old you are but your
hair is longer than i ever managed to
get my hair and wow your beard actually
came in and things along those lines um
you've written you know a book and well
and edited a book and you've got a whole
bunch of articles and
and book chapters and encyclopedia
entries and you know you've published
over 2 000 videos and a whole bunch of
podcast episodes who who the hell is
this guy
i think he would be
quite befuddled i don't know that he
would actually be able to give me
much helpful advice about where i am or
what i should do or what activities i
should prioritize and which i should
downplay
and
this is not to say that we shouldn't try
to think about how we would relate
ourselves to our earlier
versions of our self
but
i don't think we should romanticize
youth i don't think we should say oh you
know
that person
was
more squared away that person
you know had the right values and maybe
i've lost my way i mean that could be
the case for for some of you who are
watching this
that sure as hell is not the case for me
and i suspect it's not the case for
many others so you know
um
again sort of a shoot if the shoe fit
wears it if this is actually helpful
advice for you and kind of shores up
your own willingness to say to people
who try to push this thing onto you no
no man i've i'm happy assessing myself
from my own vantage point or asking my
friends and colleagues and family
members in the present i don't need to
go back to
1985
or earlier or around that time to
bring up some memory of a person who is
probably
mostly made up
you know an earlier version of myself i
don't need to do that because i can
figure things out and
assess them
here in
the present
you